touchy mache middle-class famous tour
update kippy uh-oh we got a couple
alerts going out straighten them out a
little bit yeah guys so uh we're coming
to seattle and portland unfortunately
seattle is sold out so if you want
tickets you're gonna have to come see us
in portland then we're going to kansas
city springfield st louis nashville in
the philadelphia that show sold out
already three months ahead of time we
added a second show tickets are on sale
right now then we're going up to
providence rhode island that's gonna
sell out in boston this is low ticket
alert so get those tickets now we'd love
to see you do it welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is ru garbage hey little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find out they got to be classy or if
they're just a big old piece of trash
i'm your host dave trolley coming at you
on a beautiful day bothered me
getting down to the end of the summer we
got the boys in the house [ __ ]
hanging out and tootie's upstairs she's
all excited she found the high school
kids beer stash behind a couple of
budgies good for her broad's like a
bloodhound my co-host is coming at you
from right next to me he is the ceo of
ru garbage he is an international
businessman he's the prince of park
avenue but for a couple more months he's
the king of the boardwalk baby give it
up for jj
kevin james rhymes what's up i'm for
sure going to fight tommy in the next 50
minutes uh are you mad at thomas i'm
kidding are you on once
thanks yeah in the intro jerk off
and your comments before we started
weren't that nice either
thanks for tuning in everybody please
make sure you rate view subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
as you know those numbers are
the micless t-bone from the rafters uh
then obviously the greatest website of
all time check it out [ __ ]
patreon.com [ __ ] ton of content over
there check it the [ __ ] out oh yes sir
and he has no mic but how about a nice
quick shout out to our producer shorter
yeah the magic man makes us all look
good put the whole thing together let's
give a nice big round of applause for
t-bone mcmuffin toby mcmulliner
yeah okay
you know why you don't have a mic
at the [ __ ] boys in it uh-huh you
heard about this program stuff island
yeah he's [ __ ] tearing up the charts
two of our absolute [ __ ] favorite
they're the co-hosts of the stuff island
podcast if you don't know it you got to
do yourself a [ __ ] favor check it out
their family chris o'connor tommy pope
hey gang hi guys thanks for coming both
came in
yeah you were snoring 10 minutes ago
it was nearly flawless until he hit
together
he's only ever hit 99 yeah wait when did
i stay together we're here together
together god damn it like a third grader
that's it we're doing it again
it's cause he's got a jolly rancher
under his tongue
it's a piece of gum boys how are you
good man you got a big weekend planned
you both came in with your uh your
overnights yeah tommy walked in like off
the page of gq he's got the uh he's got
the duffel bag the high shorts the socks
the shoes he's a good looking guy though
like an outfielder for the men's company
is that a new bag what is that new bag
that carry-on no it's old how old i got
new cologne no smell like that
what do you think
nah i know it's shovage
dude the commercial is insane yeah
it's johnny depp it's something like
being johnny depp's friends and you're
at a party and he rolls in with the
guitar you're like [ __ ] yeah but you
know smith pocket is full of some grammy
after about 20 minutes our music's going
to be fantastic
we should get a band together yeah this
song sucks play it again
you're real good johnny
oh good stuff boys thank you so much for
coming yeah doug said this i think three
times you're on your way down to philly
for the weekend yeah things are going
good yeah that's going great chris said
you almost you said you almost died
yesterday what happened and talking to
the mic i know you just turned into two
high school kids
you're actually we're the cops all the
time looks like we're your friend's dad
waiting for ronnie to come downstairs
yeah everything's going good mr foley
this is all right yeah
well we're a humble group yeah you're up
to something yeah
i almost died just i was i went fishing
yesterday with my brother and literally
like i was completely out of sorts
almost fell into the water what kind of
rig you are out there uh he's got i
don't know he's got just like a 86
center console boat it's nice it is nice
yeah yeah it was up like 45. pure
fishing boat that knots or mphs yeah
yeah we went over to long island we went
over to glenn glenn cloak
cove yeah not so together now
it is when you're in a hot seat
that's
yeah yeah but i like i cut i cut a line
i [ __ ] like overreally i like [ __ ]
up reeling somehow just burned a rod
sound like a great a great angler i
gotta be honest
hit my head yeah it was just you had a
cuddle i was attached to a fish no no i
just like i
i hadn't stowed one of the rods properly
and we were like jumping around so it
got wrapped around the rod next to it
and then one of the the hook on the lure
like cut
the line on the other rod
so that must be a blast to happen
it sounds like you're in a full it was
an absolute i got hit in the head yeah i
was like i was having like a meltdown by
the end i was like what the [ __ ] is
wrong were you guys drinking
no that's the problem no i didn't drink
slept without two hours that was a
problem we got up at like four are they
yelling at you like you're a green horn
my brother and he was just like he
wasn't even yelling at me that was even
worse oh he's just disappointed
he's just like doesn't want to hurt me
you know what i mean he's not good i
don't want to ruin fishing for me
that kind of stuff happened chris told a
story about his dad he's like he'd
always resonate can i tell you it's so
[ __ ] funny i think about it all the
time he goes
my dad said something to me one time and
it just it it stung so bad because he
was so disappointed he goes are you dumb
honestly just tell me
your mother and i will figure it out
if you're dumb that's okay
we'll adjust i'll play the hand i was
dealt are you dumb or not are you dumb
in the car after a while like another
miserable report card he was just like
are you stupid
genuine question yeah are you dumb
age-wise here and he literally goes
because you don't seem dumb
but if you're dumb like you'll figure it
out you're like we'll work the problem
yeah
we'll call in a
we got another son that's fine but if
you're dumb we'll get a different call
what'd you get in your report what grade
are you i mean it's all just it was high
school it was like you're a smart kid no
yeah smart sharp kid that's right but i
couldn't do school man i never
understood like school is always like a
nightmare that's usually the determining
factor
of whether you're smart or not yeah
i just can't do school dude
it was just it was always bizarre to me
when you like like i don't know they
wouldn't get a report on whatever the
french revolution and be like where's
your [ __ ] report it's like you don't
need my brother
i get that you don't
there's no doing my take on the french
revolution as a 16 year old
there's no way this is an emergency how
are you this pissed about it you know
what i mean just i'll get it to you next
week it'll also be garbage yeah it's not
casual fridays though you have to turn
your reports off
why i'll get it to you next week what is
this office space
it's not pressing
no one's gonna miss this that's a wild
mindset were you a good student tommy uh
yeah
i was really yeah i panicked that was
the opposite i was like no i wait till
like the day before and then i'd [ __ ]
that's when i shine i need i need the
pressure i need the gun to my head all
right let's figure this the [ __ ] out
it's everything in my life it's like
i let my anxiety go all the way to last
minute cram and then go why don't you
just enjoy the process it worked out he
went to drexel yeah it's a good school
yeah i was uh i did well in high school
i used to always see the kids like
taking their time like if they had a
report done in a week they'd like do a
little bit each night or like they would
be really crazy
and like getting ready and i envied it
like i was like i would love to be in
that world where it's like you know
you're sitting on your desk laying on
your bed yeah doing your homework and
you're like your friends are over and
having a good time i come home i'd watch
duck tales throw my school bag under my
bed and then go throw a ball for [ __ ]
six hours in college
imagine in college you just throw a vcr
tape in just like watch duck tales
before
at this point you're already drinking
yeah yeah
connie come on these girls want to bang
us tail spins on
a fried party like you know scrooge
mcduck
student yeah i would just sit in the
bathroom because like what the [ __ ] does
that mean well my mom would be like on
the hunt to see if i was doing my
homework and i'd be like i gotta take a
[ __ ]
and i would just literally the amount of
hours probably pretty cell phone yeah
like where you don't entertain yourself
it was literally because we had like our
childhood toys like on in a cabinet
still from when i was it was like bath
time they were just like still in there
i would literally play really open
enough duck tails [ __ ] rubber duckies
sometimes i'd hide calvin and hobbes in
there and i would just sit in there for
hours in the bathroom just reading
calvin hop that's for two hours hours
your mom wouldn't knock on the door she
would she would she would see my mom my
mom she i get two knocks and then she's
coming in
really oh yeah [ __ ] butter knife
right to that thing we had no locks on
it throw a flashbang in at me no locks
that's crazy yes
no locked doors in your house doors
really just jammed open you'd slow jerk
off in a bunk bed that's [ __ ] stupid
that was the one of the one of the most
terrifying experiences of my life i
remember being a kid
and uh my brother was pissed at me
so he had primed like the bathroom door
lock
so he had like left it open but locked
it like the little knob sure so he was
coming downstairs to like give me the
business
and i like so he started we start
getting into it wrestling i shake free i
sprint upstairs slam the door lock the
door in the bathroom and i'm like oh
safe but i had unlocked it
so literally i'd like slam the door
locked and be like oh
jesus i'll just let him cool off for a
little bit and he just got to the door
and opened it and i was like
it was a
your dad and i want to know are
we'll figure it out you're hanging from
a rope by your ankle
holy [ __ ]
you got a calvin and hops in your hand
you just put the calvin knobs in the
middle of a little loop it was straight
up like jurassic park with the guys on
the toilet and the t-rex
did you sit on the toilet yeah cause i
was like i made it
i'm safe also what else are you gonna do
in the back you're gonna sit on the
toilet i just lean against the wall like
a little i like sitting on the tub i was
just sitting on the tub guy they're like
sitting on the toilet i got hemorrhoids
by sitting on the toilet too long yeah
really yeah growing up i used to it's
the only place you could separate
yourself from my brothers and my family
we only had two bedrooms and one
bathroom to share
so i would just go in the bathroom and
like i would grab a toy tell stories it
sounds like you grew up in a shoe
that's definitely a black and white
kitchen
one bathroom with five people is a lot i
mean not a lot
a lot of people know that grab a toy and
i would do i'd i'd sit on the toilet and
the
the bathtub was right in front of you so
the curtain i acted like was um like i
would say johnny carson yeah yeah
and i'd bring like a toy for something
from my bedroom and i'd act like
uh you know there was an audience there
and i would just describe whatever i
brought into the was the toy the
audience or was he your sidekick no that
was like i was describing a toy to uh to
the crowd like hey i got it mr buttons
yeah yeah yeah did you ever get invited
to the couch
dude
i had a cabbage patch dog give me the
thumbs up
i'm doing good uh just me and richard
pride
[Laughter]
sitting next to don rickles
he'd probably take like a little glass
or like for water in the bathroom but
then he gets a little sketching soda
he's smoking a sick yeah
it's just apple juice but i thought it
was whiskey
johnny how are you
you want to see my sneaker or not
tommy i hear you were in elementary
school today that's great
you can put the nose and the ears on and
take them off if you want
johnny i tell you i'm going back to
packing a lunch
no that is a debt collector for sure
ian
do you answer wrong do you answer
numbers that you don't have
i imagine what the collection business
must be like dude it's got to be in
there i watched stock on it's [ __ ]
nuts they you just you sell the debt
collectors sell and sell themselves it's
just a random dude what i'm saying
trying to collect these days get the
[ __ ] out of here i know but it's that
much easier you just like press a but
you're not like you know yeah it's all
like computerized you're just like but
you're not like sitting in an office
like what do you want but they're not
going to make any collars [ __ ] that
way
yeah no one's [ __ ] answering well if
you do answer they're like
they got they're finally they are
stunned yeah are you dumb what are you
doing yeah just hang up and try to say
all right
send me the voicemail and you didn't
finish how you almost fell over the side
you're talking about rods
he was trying to get real nautical with
the terminology too because he's got an
eyebrow stories are always terrible
even if you catch a [ __ ] marlin you
can't tell a good story just show the
fish and that's it that's awesome no
fish
what did you bring the fish they never
no i didn't cut we didn't care how'd you
almost fall over i want to know i was
[ __ ] with the rods that i had tangled
and i was like standing on the back and
my brother was in the front of the boat
[ __ ] with like this trolling motor
because it wasn't working and so it was
like it was starting and stopping and
then we were in this like rip so the
rate waves were crashing over and a wave
just like a rogue wave hit and i went
like i literally there was a rod planted
in one of the these like little holders
and i i hit the rod just fully leaning
again thank god the rod didn't break i
could have broken a rod and gone over
but that rod held i was just like you
see what you asked for
[Laughter]
the rod almost broke
yeah
i wish it would have fallen over i
wouldn't hear that story
see well you start i'd rather go to a
funeral we haven't moved out here
i typically i typically respect your
choices as a broadcast girl when you
went back to that well i was like [ __ ]
am i getting the benefit of the now what
do you want also was that good he's a
good enough podcast he would have been
like let me get back to my story yeah
i would have fought for it
no nothing like that i heard you're at
the dentist
tell me about
that would you have to perform for the
family when you were a kid did you have
to do anything no never no no i mean you
just you tried to get a word in edgewise
i mean that's how you perform yeah
family parties knife fights yeah in a
good way
my mother's one of 11 and my my father's
one of nine so our family parties were
[ __ ] bananas yeah yeah everybody's
yapping drunk doing drugs because they
would line us up at a certain point
after dinner when they had a couple in
them and a coffee oh really yeah what
would you have to do like sing i opened
up for my cousin she did a pretty good
michael jackson
who booked that i'm telling you man she
[ __ ] she'd stopped the show she was
unbelievable a singer uh no she just did
the dance moves with the hat and the
glove and all that stuff been that good
i'm telling you man
yeah she was good the dad had to leave
the room
it's very embarrassing my father would
never allow that oh really yeah do you
guys have anyone that would like play
the piano no so we had some of that we
had one guy come over with a we're at
we're at my cousin's house who was like
a little bit of more distant you know
what i mean he wasn't like really in the
we're really in the fold yeah and he had
a friend oh like that uncle or whoever
had a friend over i don't know who this
guy was he still gets made fun of 25
years later he broke out an acoustic
guitar
in front of a bunch of [ __ ] you know
a bunch of pipefitters exactly dudes
for a living and it was no way
[Laughter]
yeah guys would still have spackle on
their hands
i'm gonna sit there and watch you play
free bird
you cannot bring an instrument to that
party
when you're a kid
[Music]
zero guitar you got a sniper rifle in
there right
i'll kill myself with that sniper rifle
if it's not
oh
[ __ ] look man i was on a plane one
time and the pilot got on and had a
guitar in his back i was like [ __ ] [ __ ]
start yelling bomb
that's [ __ ] hippie [ __ ]
i had that it was about one christmas
party i got a karaoke somebody i think
was a karaoke machine
and my mom made me
i was
like oh no
dude
i can't believe i never thought she was
trying to find some life in you put your
fat little ass up there and do something
this is the story of a girl
little tough guy my dad would be like i
don't know you had a daughter
he's wearing his mom's juicy sweatsuit
oh [ __ ] she's 13.
a pair of uggs on some fake gold
i look like jlo
i'm still kippy
there's a fat kid in velour
hitting the wrong notes
[ __ ] moose knuckles sticking out
ah you stink
how can i picture that scene so clearly
i remember my uncle then turning around
i can't look at you right now pilot
goggles
being around the world tonight
i got a yellow jumpsuit
getting all swishy and [ __ ]
i'm sticking to my couch
uncle then just parks turkey in like a
[ __ ] ziploc bag i'm like i can't do
this i gotta go
is this the nieces kid
kayla let's talk about butcher box
let me issue a question for both sides
because they're one of my favs what do
you think of when you think of a high
quality meal do you think of some of the
stuff they have in the grocery store
with the antibiotics gray chicken and
stuff band-aids on them and the needles
sticking out of them and the dirt ball
that's handling them or do you think
about grass-fed grass finished
free-range wild caught
called is that what you think about it
that's what i think about obviously
because i'm a butcher box [ __ ] guy
right had a little butcher box yesterday
i know that oh my god i love ground beef
in a bit i still got ground beef coming
out of my [ __ ] he's thank you so
goddamn much uh butcher box takes the
guesswork out of finding high quality
meat and seafood you can trust 100
grass-fed like the big man said free
range pork raised crepe-free wild-caught
seafood uh humanely raised no
antibiotics no added hormones
it's the ultimate convenience baby just
quality just what you want delivered
right to your door doorstep free
shipping for the continental us and no
surprise fees choose from a variety of
box plans options from curated to
customized because they know what they
do they know what it works they know
what everybody likes so you can go with
the ones they got or you can do your own
and you can change your plan whenever
you want enjoy a range of high quality
cuts that are hard to come by at your
local grocery store uh at an amazing
value uh they have exclusive member
deals you can save big uh save big on
your favorite cuts
uh like we said time and time again they
were nice enough to send them to us it's
fantastic you do we do the ragus we do
the sausage we got everything for nice
um
so here it is take chicken breasts off
your grocery list strap it are you
kidding me take chicken breasts off your
grocery list first it's hamburger all
right first is fresh ground beef
then they're giving away bacon for like
what are they doing with the chickens
butcher boxes offering our listeners an
incredible deal that they've never
offered before free chicken for a year
you're joking
you're joking get two pounds of free
range organic chicken breasts for free
and everyone's hiding out in the fields
behind the bushes and you sign up at
butcherbox.com ayg i'm gonna start going
i'm gonna start going to different
lobbies and stealing the packages
that's a deal claim this deal deal at
butcherbox.com ayg do it let's talk
about ladder baby ladder let's talk
about how precious life is let's talk
about not [ __ ] hanging your folks out
to dry when you when you go down the
tubes listen we we if you're anything
like us we've been screwing over our
whole family all of our lives don't
leave them holding the bag when you're
dead and go and do one i still plan to
it's one solid thing you can do as you
ease off into into hell where most of us
are going
bring the suntan lotion gang do yourself
a favor go over the ladder get yourself
some term life there's no needles
there's no doctors you do it all online
it's easy peasy you don't got to worry
about anything gives you a little bit of
peace of mind yeah guys there's no
hidden fees you can't sell any time get
a full refund if you change your mind in
the first 30 days because they're good
peeps over there uh you can find out if
you're instantly approved because they
got smart algorithms over there on our
website to do it all real quick after
the application finally since life
insurance cost more as you age now is
the time to cross it off your list so go
to latter life dot com garbage today to
see if you're instantly approved that's
ladder l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
garbage ladderlife.com garbage dead
karaoke
now we didn't have none of that [ __ ]
you were doing it dry
i was a showman all right i don't know i
didn't need all the who's it
i didn't have any [ __ ] any of that
[ __ ] i was [ __ ] you in the
audience
and they were a tough crowd after a
couple of [ __ ]
bud ponies really i didn't loosen them
up
what was your act i did uh
wrinkles
three hot dogs in 30 seconds
and then regurgitate them
after thanksgiving dinner
patty we can't have him do this no don't
worry he doesn't show up again charlie
no i did uh i did uh robin leech i did
him wait
i would do that and i would do a crazy
eddy impersonation that would bring the
house down crazy eddie who was that he
was like uh
not now the stereos crazy eddie prices
are insane oh god all right your cousins
are because he's in the wings just feel
like he's doing eddie again
it's always kills how am i supposed to
follow this this [ __ ] should be closing
getting all mad
oh suck a dick i'm dead
so you almost fell in huh
[Laughter]
unbelievable
you did say something pretty crazy right
before we started uh
recording everything he says is pretty
cool that churches are now turning into
nightclubs yeah i didn't believe was
that this business is so bad in the
religion business
they're not making enough money
so that's why they're getting all this
like sound stuff because at night they
throw parties
dude i don't think this is happening oh
it is on this
yeah i mean it's not happening in like
the scary catholic ones yet yeah
but just wait those like those they
can't get the permits
yeah the ones with the band yeah the
moss the protestants the process
protestants
they're queen's to get they're starting
to get down that's why you go to like a
like kind of like a cool church you know
we would never no we were catholic
church i remember the one time they on
like sunday like the lighthearted they
had a guitarist yeah that was my dad big
turning point you're only getting half
the [ __ ] donation i was playing
there's nothing worse than music at a
church unless it's black music like
white music no that's trying to be cool
with the catholics if you just do the
organ that's it yeah
for sure oh hosanna was all right yeah
i'm not talking about the classics i'm
talking about the guys that trying to
trashing it up you know like
youth pastor type stuff no you get rid
of that stuff you keep that [ __ ] real
solemn and real [ __ ] straight up the
middle yeah you get some heavy set lady
to do the singing yeah play the organ
and that's it yeah i want to picture my
mom like this yeah i want to see her in
a casket when i hear you sing at the
church yeah that was a big no-no with us
when they the sundays they do like the
guy came in with like a couple like
somebody had the [ __ ] what are those
things
yeah tambourines
yeah
that [ __ ] that only lasted for like a
month maybe and every i think at the
next meeting or whatever
that's like big like baptist church [ __ ]
in the middle of the country that's
crazy [ __ ] white people yeah
but
at a black church
man they can throw down i've been i've
been twice and it was unbelievable i
went to one when i went to drexel in
west philly crazy the band of cotton's
memorial was
they were like the [ __ ] five
heartbeats i was doing
i was doing the electric slide midway
through [ __ ] those guys were killing
it
they were killing
it but there was a buffet it was like an
event yeah oh man
not ron with his guitar on [ __ ] the
five o'clock mass on saturday it's like
let's go dick out our pizzas
we hit a hit we hit an easter vigil or
something one time like by accident
we're like oh we'll go to the midnight
mass knock it out quick it ended up
being like 14 hours people were being
baptized
they were doing like all the sacraments
the night before easter yeah or the
night yeah whatever we thought we were
going to not be we're like oh we'll go
it'll be 50 minutes we're getting out
the [ __ ] door i mean khakis won't
even unwrinkle exactly nope wrong dude
that's we had like cousins from ireland
come over and go to like american
catholic church it's like an hour and
change yeah and they were like what the
[ __ ] hours
they got their lunch pails with them
yeah dude they're like 30 minutes they
could build a bridge in that time
you're on your knees for five hours
i just need god to see that i was here i
don't need your [ __ ] appearance yeah
you know what i mean shake some hands
plug the website keep it moving we used
to leave after my dab i go with my dad
on sundays
we used to leave after communion yeah
every time that's the move dude i used
to hide under the deck i used to go to
the church
grab the deck yeah grab one of the uh
what do you call them the little piece
of paper that says what church i'm still
trying to figure out the bulletin
the bulletin the program i go to because
you have to show your your parent my
parent like which cl which mass you went
to the 10 the 11. you were going with
your family to church this is when i was
a little older i was like 10 11 13.
that's not that much older it's an
octopus you still go to church together
what were they doing 10 years old that's
all you walked a [ __ ] mess by
yourself on a sunday why why would they
not be going with you that's my mother's
a nurse she was like worked like 12
hours sometimes and your dad wasn't
going my dad never went to church nice
unless it was a funeral yeah he grow up
castle like grab a bullet you can still
hide under breakfast
had those eggs
he [ __ ] did he wouldn't make
breakfast like two hours yeah i have the
home fries ready when i get home
scrapple takes 45 easy low and slow
that's how he gets a perfect crisp
look at this
he's just it takes it takes 10 minutes
he's just making up excuses
you know how long scrapple takes
he didn't need anything when you boil a
hot dog it takes at least an hour and a
half you got it slow and slow but
seriously i would go in my backyard and
hide under the deck and i would just sit
there and just like play with like a
[ __ ] baseball or tennis ball so you'd
run down to church you'd get the
bulletin yeah i'd have a friend get a
bolton sometimes too i'd like yo can you
get me bulletin whatever mess you're
going to and then pick it up from him
and then give it to my parents later
running scams back then huh that's
pretty good [ __ ] no-show job at
church yeah i would never show up if it
was up to me yeah yeah i knew i was
going i i even stopped going i would do
for a longest time i would do christmas
and easter yeah just for like for my mom
and family and then like at one point
i'm like yo [ __ ] this insane i'm done
i'm done with this i will get i'll get
an apartment when a church becomes an
apartment i love i love the idea of that
when all the churches become apartments
oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah
jesus christ
[Laughter]
a lot of time under that deck huh
my first year at temple
there was a huge class it was like it
held like 400 people like one of those
like you know intro to business like 101
or whatever so it was like hundreds of
people were supposed to be in there and
they had this new technology where you
had to buy like a clicker like a little
remote
and you would walk in and like to
register that you were there you would
click yeah like you didn't so we would
just would take turns and we'd send one
person with like thirty-five
it was like the first 10 minutes they
were explaining i'm like i'm going to
abuse the [ __ ] out of this you know like
veteran teachers like the teachers i had
at drexel for engineering they didn't
give a [ __ ] so like you you're spending
a lot of money it's like you have to
make the most of it if you don't want to
come if you percent i have that was my
favorite professor i was like you can
come yeah if you get the work done he's
like everything online you can figure it
the [ __ ] out show up the first day and
the last night i don't care yeah not
that yeah those are the classes i did
the best in 100 otherwise i'm not doing
the [ __ ] project out of spite and
i'll figure it out next week yeah you
know the best part about college is like
you got to figure this [ __ ] out on your
own and the teachers
i was not good at that no no i was too
babied for any of that stuff where'd you
go widener universe widener okay what a
[ __ ] whole town
it's a jester i know yeah that's a bad
campus
i've been there get some goodies
probably for the wrong reasons yeah you
weren't going to check out the grounds
going oh she had spongebob sheets
going to the new church down there
it was a nightclub
all right gang let's get into this
it's always fun with the boys here good
time with the stuff island boys you got
to do yourselves a favor check out the
pod check out the page i mean you just
did it that past like two or three weeks
sure yeah yeah um
i confessed to making out with a man it
was awesome yeah that got a lot of
reviews yeah that was did you they liked
the kippy episode no no but it was a
woman it was enough do you remember that
i mean you were there you gave me the
money to buy the drink remember standing
out front of the lantern and uh that
girl in a red dress came by and we
started i started making out with her
was this the matrix
what are you talking about
whatever moving on um
yeah then i thought she was a guy
because she was so hot and so into you
yeah that makes sense
that's exactly thank you yeah
something ain't right
yeah either
you're a dude or you're an artificial
assassin
ex machina
uh yeah as you know so when uh
you sign up for the patreon we will
answer your garbage question on the air
just the best way to do it uh
so this one's for mike james is it
garbage if your vehicle is in the
parking lot of the strip club on google
street view
that's a [ __ ] badge of honor i would
say yeah it's pretty sick or you're
unlucky
yeah it's pretty bad especially if you
have like a very s distinct car you know
what i mean how do you find that roxy
with
well it's definitely garbage because
you're clearly there during the day
well maybe he's responsible he takes a
cab home after uh you know oh there you
yeah a couple go
i like how you wanna i like how you're
giving them the benefit you're like you
know this guy could be a great [ __ ]
guy yeah maybe his car broke down there
you know he spilled some buffalo wing
sauce all over the place he's already
had to use this excuse
anyway it's not garbage tony uh did you
have a go-to uh gentleman's club in
philadelphia one that you frequented i
went once every like i'll go once every
10 years by chance with like a couple
dudes to be funny
i hate it yeah i don't like it at all we
went not too long ago with um
yeah thanks for the invite santino
isn't it more garbage that he saw that
on how would you say how do you find
that yeah he's going down
are you google mapping the [ __ ] strip
club or if he was there and saw the
google car drive by and was like oh
[ __ ] yeah but they got me you see those
cars all the time it's not like
everything makes the final cut
i mean i don't know who's editing this
thing
i think that's more lame yeah do you
think there's a there's like a someone
who's gotta choose the photos be like oh
this is a good one it's a sweet life i
think so yeah have you ever fallen off a
boat that one's from chris
[Laughter]
uh this one's from milk bean mike did
you ever put your school lunches in a
wonder bread bag [ __ ] yeah that's a
tough look charlie's hamburgers used to
sell their hamburgers in the
in a bread bag
so then that's how i got the idea i was
like this is cool i can like show my
friends charlie's hamburgers yeah where
was that at folsom pa really they moved
but it's the best cheeseburger you'll
ever have and they would fast food style
they would put them in
they would run through so many rolls and
so many burgers they only sold burgers
and chips there's no like side items
uh-huh i love a place that just does
like that's how you do one thing you do
one thing and you do it better than
everybody else they put them in wax
sleeves throw them in the in the roll
bag itself mm-hmm and then they give you
the bag really yeah and you could see
the meat and the [ __ ] ketchup and
mustard in the bag and then
you know that's
from home here today and my mom gave me
an apple and a new york times newspaper
bag
why why wait a half just an hour just an
apple oh my god
why do you need a bag for that i don't
that's like putting horses in a bed
why don't you think you can read the new
york times no the times wasn't in there
it's just the apple just one apple no
drink oh she gave me the bag from the
new york yeah
that's why
to do it as a kid going to elementary
school you just did it today
i know it's never the newspaper bread
something
you know yeah there's no ink all over
the apple one apple like i would feel so
weird like it's like buying condoms
without getting a pack of gum it's like
throw something in the bag
is it supposed to be like a weapon on
the train
i don't know she just handed it to me
and we had such a nice time together
that i wasn't gonna be like what the
[ __ ] is this
that's nice i was just like all right
i'm taking it
i think about it once a week are you
dumb
just tell me now did you pack your lunch
as a young man going to school
personally
i know you didn't do that
yeah no i got locked yourself in the
bathroom
yeah now pack lunches bologna sandwich
mustard your mom would do it yeah okay
but i love bologna sandwiches bunny
sandwiches are all right i love bologna
sandwiches on what white bread yeah so
did every soldier in world war one right
nobody eats i would have i would have
had bread it was a baguette
yeah what did you eat for lunch
uh similar something like that salami
and cheese was a big one that big salami
and cheese on white bread with mustard
wrap that up and like for some reason
some kind yes metamorphosis
dude i still i'll still take a piece of
provolone put some um dijon and then a
piece of generous salami do a little
rollatini oh yeah
that's [ __ ] keto baby that's that's
and that's in vogue right yeah just
because the deli meats were like that's
all you had at like family parties just
deli meat out sweaty [ __ ] cheese you
hit that cheese like three couple pieces
of rye bread
my god
it is so good just eating meat yeah
mustard's got a little crust on it
slices of meat locked nice i still do
that a couple of seven and seven glasses
floating around there i'm going to rip a
[ __ ] might [ __ ] a burger after this
[Laughter]
on the train you ever get so hungry you
get horny tommy didn't make it to philly
what happened man i let him off into
caucus
buddy life saver i got to tell you
something what's that three words
liquid hydration
summer okay what are those things you
have to do together you got to put them
all together have a good hopefully
summer 16 ounces of water
stick a liquid iv how many times faster
do you think it hydrates you over water
maybe one time oh one time yeah cause
you're a bozo one and a half times two
two times faster more inflation gets in
there quicker do yourself a favor liquid
iv is delicious i use it for my workouts
i use it for me through you know yeah
not bad for a hangover buddy i gotta be
honest with you they sent us i got
liquid iv coming out the wazoo and i
feel rushing through it i feel like
frank lucas with it because i got my
whole family hooked on it i took it down
the shore where we all do our boozing
oh my god they were they were scratching
their necks knocking on the front door
i'm going through a bag of the pina
colada right now that's delicious dude
they got the b3 the b5 the b6 the b12
vitamin c it contains three times the
electrolytes in traditional sports
drinks made with freeman ingredients
liquid iv is free from gluten dairy and
soy it is
fantastic they use cellular transport
technology designed to enhance rapid
absorption of water and other key
ingredients into the bloodstream these
guys are playing chestnut checkers over
there all right all those other sports
drinks and kick rocks i'm a liquid iv
man grab your liquid iv in bulk
nationwide at costco or you can get 50
off when you go to liquidive.com use
code garbage at checkout that's 15 off
anything you order when you shop better
hydration today using promo code garbage
at liquidity.com do it are you taking
amtrak yeah how you guys getting amtrak
yeah what i don't know if you knew
jersey trains at dirtbag yeah we're
making a couple of shekels now the delay
is is why brutal i used to do that [ __ ]
like you know amtrak 53 minutes or
whatever an hour and time yeah hours and
five minutes taking the excellent first
class
this drives me [ __ ] nuts it's a
difference of 10 minutes the seller and
it's like 200 dollars more expensive
yeah the seller to boston is worth it
yeah but the sell out of philly it's
worst cafe car their cafe car sucks
so [ __ ] bad they got stools
i like a bench with a table yeah no it's
like a diner it's like a diner booth to
me and my buddy the one night we were
going down to philly we got like a beer
for the table yeah they tried to make it
like futuristic and cool it's like the
future sucks
the way it was is perfect
just leave it
you need my bolognese dude i remember
the first kind of apple in there
someone mail me a sandwich oh my god
dude
the first time i wrote a show you bought
the wires of sandwich it's a vanilla
folder
first time i wrote a cell i was the most
excited i was to see the cafe car yeah
because i was rocking the cafe car and
the regular was like i can't i can't
even imagine what they're doing on a
cello
the food's probably it's probably
lobster and [ __ ]
and it was absolute it's an empty
hallway he's still talking about it
and like holds on to it forever his face
gets all red you see he's like [ __ ]
veins do you ever go to like a really
wealthy person's house
and their remotes don't work
it's like the best feeling in the world
because you go oh we're all the same
yeah you guys are far now yeah yeah yeah
yeah i just got one tv the remote that
came with it it works perfect you have
10 different things you're managing and
none of it works you don't have to call
a guy
[ __ ] you
you did too much
then they go up to their [ __ ]
their giant circle bed with their
supermodel wife
may be funny
[Applause]
i know that they're [ __ ] their wife
but they're not fully in it they're
thinking about the [ __ ] remote no i
think about their secretary they're all
so yeah
you're not the thing that guy's worried
about the remote you're worried about
the remote because that's all you have
and he's worried about his poor shoes he
drove her yeah his boat and when are you
going
when are you going to rich people's
houses where you would have access to
their remotes
yeah he dabbles in both worlds yeah okay
i got an uncle
it's nice yeah he got us a bank of
america
did he yeah that's exact uncle yeah your
uncle had to get you guys a bank account
that's a big weight come on
yeah
i have it i have a drink
i can get a bank account
this guy ain't putting apples in my
newspaper
[Laughter]
she's also dumb yeah no these guys
they're very every little detail bothers
them
so i know rich people yeah i also think
you're taking one rich guy you know and
extrapolated that against no they're all
the same who's also related to you so
like he's not his gene pulls a little
contamination
he just got lucky yeah dude i don't get
why that's the burn the remote doesn't
matter it's out of batteries that's
justification no it's your life
like the ice maker didn't work
or like the dishwasher was broke
or ripping the screen door ripping the
screen door i'll give you that
everything the remote what the remote
but the remote is i mean look the man in
the house probably isn't doing the rich
man of the house isn't doing dishes so
he might not see that the washing
machine's broke
but he knows the tv's not working
he can't not know you're a psycho
it's unbelievable
every time i talk to there's just
another lay where i'm like yeah oh no
you're crazy
you're absolutely it's [ __ ] funny do
you think you could kill somebody
uh probably definitely yeah
definitely definitely probably look at
the kind of guys like to take his time
to do it
let him think about it you'd walk into
the police station covered in blood too
be like i do think about that
you and i like fighting too much like
podcasters yeah oh and killing them nah
just like really having that's a
challenge no i mean i was we this i was
kind of talking about this the other day
well like i watched this show have you
seen like uh blackbird or whatever no
it's this show on apple tv it's not very
good the guy the main character is like
he's like so i watch it all the time
but he's like a theater guy who got
jacked and like doesn't know he walks
around like crazy he's like so
ridiculously jacked it's upsetting but
anyway
he's just for the listener this might
not be a real show
i just wanted i was just at their house
they don't even have it
just the way this guy moves in the show
is so distracting it's impossible to
watch
just putting that out there but
he told this like his character in the
story when he's a kid his stepdad is a
piece of [ __ ] and one day he like he
comes home to like beat beat up his
stepdad he finally thinks he's big
enough and his stepdad kicks the [ __ ]
out of him and then [ __ ] his mom
like in the room next to him like hard
and loud yeah and i was like if i were
that kid i would kill that dude really
first 100 i would kill that guy yeah
yeah just for banging your mom yeah just
like it's murder it's time to murder
somebody yeah you know what i mean and i
think it's it is it's time to clock gang
when else are you like that's you kill
that person it's it's better to like
you can't live past that yeah but
without that guy he's dead you're going
full crazy
if you make them scarred or limp forever
it's more powerful
if you can't if you corner that you name
them yeah
if you corner that dude and you
literally break his arm in a certain way
it can't it can't function anymore give
him a limp he's got to look at himself
in the mirror every day and think of you
or castration
how do you get there you poison him i
know you hit him with him you got to
immobilize in the knees or you knock him
out cold without him knowing like yeah
but anytime
anytime you hit someone in the head with
a bat
no no
[Laughter]
you guys are found on the dark web right
that's really that's right nickelodeon
turned you down huh i'm just saying your
stepdad kicks your ass then he [ __ ]
your mom and i'm giggling in the room
next to you you kill him wait why is she
getting
wait
the mom's giggling too yes well she's
got a guy are you killing her as well
you're not gonna let her hang around and
the house is yours now you guys are
finally coming around are you killing
her as well what you killing her as well
uh no but you'll pound her after let her
know what a real name
oh that's through drawing the line it's
his mother for crying he's about to kill
somebody
he already did i think in this reality
kill this step dad
he's got to die anyway what's the next
question
you guys ever make nachos in the
microwave
is this this is this is this is this is
this
is
this
is
this
is
this
is
this
is this
is
this
is
this
is
this
is
this
is this
is
this
is
this
is
this
is
this
is this
is
this
is
this
is
this
is
this
is this is this is this is this made up nah
this is from james swear to god have you
ever made nachos by microwaving american
cheese over the classic round or uh
tortillas
i made nachos in the microwave at 4am
last night really yeah sober
4am yeah yeah yeah
what kind of cheese you use rummy throw
it because you're a cook you're a chef
or a chef you're a cook as long as the
chip is is of decent quality and cheese
no no no that's what are we doing that's
garbage
no these are the uh like the mexican
style yeah
but they're like restaurants restaurants
we've tried actual
no no no you got to get the brick never
get shredded cheese it dries out they
usually you took the brick and then you
you chopped just ready to break yourself
never buy priests really you're in there
slicing cheese at four i got a [ __ ]
yes it's got a two seconds you were
crazy
yeah he's he's hammered microwaving
nachos at 4 am still won't eat bag
cheese meanwhile o'connor's sleeping in
a coffin let me explain
we're in a clown suit
he drops down from the ceiling thank you
guys
preservatives that keep it dried and not
clump yeah it has to stay separated on
the [ __ ] okay
it does have a consistency so you get
the cracker barrel you shred it yourself
get a block and shred it stop being so
[ __ ] lazy all right
and then i i only put pepper flake i
didn't put any toppings on it little
scallion
did you doing scallions on [ __ ]
microwaves where you shredded the cheese
you wouldn't know
i know i'm saying that's crazy
microwave if i put that in front of your
face
of course i'm not judging you tell me
that's not homemade go ahead
you're waking up o'connor
it's 4 30 i'm like [ __ ] try
you gotta unstrap him out of his
restraints
it's just me it's just me easy doesn't
it
it's just your buddy tommy yeah you
definitely sleep the bed's standing up
in your room don't take off your eyes
okay it's okay it's okay hey don't hit
me don't hit me don't hit me
seven different sleep sounds going you
got rain you've got screaming
what is your alarm by the way your wake
up alone i don't have one
what do you mean i just wake up but what
if you have a flight or something that
just wake up shut up
like cramer
i like every once in a while i said
alarm but i usually have like a 7 a.m
flight unless i'm hammered i will wake
up
will you wake up perfectly on time yeah
why not it's not always perfect
sometimes i wake up sometimes i'm five
minutes early
and when you're i assume you get up you
get in the shower are you already packed
for the night from the night no no no no
no i rushed off
yeah did either one of you pack dirty
clothes to go down to philly this
weekend never uh kidding no but i have
done that before yeah that's just like a
go-to move yeah really you'd watch
my mom like i'm going down if i'm going
on the shore or something on the washer
no i'll do it but there's a washer i
might leave it in the dryer's jeep
you don't have more clothes that are
clean you could just [ __ ] grab a
second shirt oh wait so you're talking
about going home bringing dirty laundry
no i'll go to my mom i'll like go to the
down the shore or whatever yeah oh yeah
bring dirty everybody's wearing dirty
clothes and wow
i would go so far as to wash them at the
end of the weekend too so i'm coming
back with fresh clothes definitely i do
that all the time when i go to patties
yeah definitely yeah she's good yeah and
she will wash them yeah i'm not going to
wash herself she doesn't want me
touching her what don't you your mom
does your laundry of course she does
it's her house he like defends it like
it's crazy to me first of all he's also
50 years old i started at like well i
think i was like 10 years old we had to
start doing our own laundry
i couldn't use an iron if you [ __ ]
gave me a million it's different than a
wash i mean you should know how to use
an iron i know how to use a washer i
don't know how to use a washer and dryer
it's getting the shirt on the board
that's really the type of really it's
really lining up the seams yeah i don't
care why can you iron yeah i used to
work at a dry cleaner
it's not [ __ ] chinese yeah no i know
i i mean we started at a very young age
too my mom
wrote it out on like [ __ ] like poster
boys like this is what you do for dishes
cut
people that don't do their laundry say
[ __ ] like that you don't do anything no
my mom's just taking the laundry
i always cut the grass you don't cook
you don't clean i don't do your
laundry trash out what do you do i clean
the garage when it needs to get cleaned
i put the storm when you're one of these
old-fashioned does your mother take care
of your father like this did he well no
yeah yeah i but don't do that
this is how you reverse it yeah
the mother treats the father like a
[ __ ] child and it ruins the family no
i love that i love this [ __ ] i love that
the siblings don't know how to do
anything when they get to college you're
learn how to [ __ ] cook
get them out of catholic school it
doesn't do anything learn cpr not
religion the book of ezekiel could suck
my dick learn how to suck another man's
mouth if he passes out
tommy how do you do your own laundry i
don't want to do that anymore just pump
yeah you don't go mouth-to-mouth and i
heard pump yeah chain told us
and tommy i don't even have kids i know
right
you should you'd be a great father
thanks yeah as long as you do it on
laundry you'd leave them early but you
know
uh
yeah plus the mom likes doing the
laundry she does that's a bad excuse but
it's not it's
good
don't let her do it she
[Music]
[Applause]
she does it better than me dude she's a
grandmother she's like she doesn't
believe in this woman let me ask you
this a lot of people do [ __ ] better than
me i still do it myself let's say you
had to go in for surgery okay you could
do the surgery okay but the surgeon does
it really good who's gonna do the
surgery i would exactly yeah i would if
the surgeon was a 90 year old woman i
would do the surgery i think i'm sorry
for bestowing this that's issues she's
the matriarch she likes doing certain
things yeah she wouldn't let me touch
her watching her washing machine yeah
don't touch my washing machine i go you
go no you old broad shut up and go sit
down i'm 46 years old i'm a man i should
be a man i will do my i'll tell you what
once i'm not talking about it actually
makes you look weak that you have to you
have to stand on the laundry oh jesus
could be
do your laundry guys that are taking you
can tell people that are taken care of
as a child because they don't know how
to keep themselves
also if you were just like hey you think
an apple in a new york times bag is
taken care of that's true she sent him
out like he was a [ __ ] like he was
going to look for doc work you're broken
listen you you're training a child i'm
like tommy yeah yeah tommy's not broken
at all tommy's got his whole life in
order there's no question oh this is how
we prank him
yeah yeah he might be crazy but he
doesn't shrink button down i'll tell you
that
[Laughter]
this guy's a [ __ ] whiz with the
fabric softener
uh light wash light drops
do you have anything that you do in the
sink
like anything delicate that you do in
the sink with like a little wool light
or anything like that i could see your
panties or anything
and they sync with oh you mean like
washing the same hand wash no i do uh
i'm very close with my my laundry guys
so now i have a separate bag for things
i don't want dried so i'll hand them
like a separate bag smart these i don't
want driving they hang them up and fold
them for me oh really that's nice i
should do that because i stopped going
to my guy
they [ __ ] because they tortured him
where'd you do
this buddy
yeah unless it's a t-shirt you have to
like even the t-shirts they come back
and they're and i'm like come on
graphics like just it's just
i don't know i've never seen it
did you put this in the broiler
[Laughter]
i would love to know what the world
looks like through your eyes i swear to
god man
all right let's do uh let's do one or
two more that's not great
let's do one or two more here um
sometimes the water comes rushing up
it's high tide all the time maybe a
couple rogue waves flash floods always
always a siren going on
the lights are always blinking none of
the shopping carts work
all right this one's from the new york
savage first time long time 10 homie
uh wait no i lied that's not that person
uh this is from dennis anyone have
trauma from their parents ripping their
baby teeth out as a child
what
my brother put i did it myself
but he tied it the string to the door
that's the trashiest way to do it i've
seen the hockey puck was pretty cool i
saw that on like youtube or some [ __ ]
the brother someone shot a hockey player
that's all right i thought you meant
they shot it in his face
kid must be a dead eye huh why not just
let it come out
because you got to get the views about
it you pull it out you pull it out you
just wiggle it out because you get money
so you're always trying to get some
[ __ ] bread yeah did you not get the
tooth fairy
uh yeah we got the tooth fairy but we
weren't ripping our teeth out to get the
money
we were doing well enough that's real
right
full of baloney sandwiches
she should have gave you another apple
at the time i had an ipo that was doing
very good
[Laughter]
you hold on to your teeth as long as you
can that's why it's working for you not
the other guy
real rich guy
time value money yeah
why would i give someone else my team
[Laughter]
put it on a credit card don't worry
about it just make sure you pay it at
the end of the month
but you make more teeth
but you had to get one done like that
with the door yeah at some point you're
like petrified my mom would be like your
dad or let your brother
we tried the door maybe as like a [ __ ]
yeah you did it once that's what i'm
saying but ours was [ __ ] just pulled
out with a little piece of paper towel
together
yeah you do it take care i remember i
remember my dad yelling me one time like
that dude's coming out today yeah like
we're not tired of hearing we're not
doing this it's gotta get the [ __ ] out
what yeah we gotta get it in the stock
market you know what i mean if your
mother tells me one more time you got a
loose [ __ ] tooth come on uh-huh
garage because you're just walking
around bitching about it yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah exactly yeah yeah well and you
can i remember just the fibers so you
could hear it like
it would get to the point where like
because the gum would not like die but
like the nerve endings would die so you
could be like you wouldn't fear oh
wiggle oh what makes my blood run cold
thinking about it
we just let it live
you did yeah i liked wiggling it
probably just swallowed yours
you're like a puppy yeah
shits them out yeah the first time you'd
be like ah it's wiggling
it's gonna fall out
yeah that was it go play on your boat
yeah go go away
jesus
finish your polo
[Laughter]
yeah it's gotta rip it out of your skull
to get you to shut the [ __ ] up
my dad was like stop complaining it's
coming out just relax and that was the
end of it
what did your dad do for a living he's
an engineer all right
okay
when he turns into the number eight you
better [ __ ] you better get on your
horse
i thought he was gonna hit me dude
he's waiting for one of your stupid
[ __ ] jokes on your comedy podcast
say something yeah
he drops below the mic he's like he's an
engineer
i don't even know what the [ __ ] we were
just saying next question
he's an engineer
what else she got a piece of [ __ ]
whose beats are they
they could be yours yeah are they are
they uh merch they're up for grabs it's
for real because the mine just broke
okay my headphones okay maybe i'm bored
for a trip
you can't borrow it [ __ ] yeah what i
want to put back in your after they're
in your ears i got clean ears i clean my
ears every day how do you clean your
ears every day okay where the cute thing
is
when you say something i wouldn't have
yelled at you i would have lowered my
eyebrows
my mother does them for me
i drive down to philly every night and
she doesn't let's wrap it up
gang we love you we [ __ ] love yous
have a great weekend stuff island do
yourself a favor check them out boys you
got anything else you want the folks
they're gonna know hit up plug away yeah
we're gonna um we're gonna we're gonna
add a lot more cooking videos um i'm
sorry for the we do high-end productions
and we're gonna do some
moderate products look at this look at
the show on patreon check out their
patreon patreon's
are catching up to our our free
programming but the patreon is is is
worth the five dollars what free
programming it is it's funny way you
said it let me get this out because we
never [ __ ] plug anything i think it's
telling us
[Applause]
tommy's only got so many you know what
i'm sure
this is why we don't say nothing
wait you do have a you enjoy the free
[ __ ] youtube
you do have you do have one episode of
look at dish up on youtube right that
everybody can see the third one up on
friday for free because it's it's
sponsored by uh trough yeah okay great
what are you doing fantastic we got a
lot of sponsors now shout out fanny
she's the [ __ ] best shout out to her
get out
give me what do
i don't know check out whatever whenever
hey listen to our band i guess just do
you baby man i'm just out here living
life yeah if you like it you like you
whatever man don't tell nobody about it
if you're in the amtrak snack car later
come up and say hi guys
the future sucks
[Music]
no we're regular we're back to baseball
gang we're all over the road get some
[ __ ] tickets the tickets are selling
out don't [ __ ] snooze on it uh we had
a second show in philadelphia that's
gonna [ __ ] go too boston's about to
sell out provinces they're gonna sell it
get those [ __ ] pickies come see us
gang we love you boys we love you t-bone
love you love you we'll see you next
week